all right well many of us rely on coffee
to operate every day and today's the
perfect day
for a latte it is national latte day
hector mejia live this morning with the
secret behind the perfect cup hector
used to be a barista
good morning to you hector
i used to be for a very brief moment hey
there alex i have a question for you
okay
so what did the coffee cup say to its
date
what hey there hot stuff
[Laughter]
anyway so we're talking about national
latte day we're at the lgbtq center here
at the jolt coffee this is tiffany who's
going to show me how to do what
we're going to make a caramel macchiato
so you made a latte before so this is a
little more of an intricate drink
you're going to pull your espresso shot
right now which button
out of the 50. double there double let's
make it a double okay
and we're going to pull that and that's
our zap espresso that we're pulling
you can really smell it you know what's
so unique when you roast
your own coffee beans is not only the
aroma but also
the flavor yes sometimes you don't even
need sugar yeah
because the cot the coffee is naturally
sweet enough
so it should pull a nice sweet shot for
all right so you guys have a blend
called the pride blend
proceeds some of them go toward the
center here yes
absolutely and then you're just going to
add that right here
oh let me grab that yeah all right milk
vanilla milk delicious okay so just pour
it on top
any specific way or just dump it just
dump it yeah all right here we go
nice well it's not as pretty as yours
but i'll come around the yeah
and then so you're going to do a design
on here did you want to give it a whirl
all right as i work on this design here
tell us about how people can um
score free coffee you can come
if you come onto our website and join us
for a roasting experience um we also
give a free latte with the roasting
experience or
if you buy our pride blend um here that
a portion of it goes back to the center
but we are also giving free lattes if
you buy the pride blend
throughout the rest of the month
throughout the rest of the month that's
great to hear
so i i understand someone ordered some
extra
sugar right yeah this is yours oh yeah
yeah i think i had enough
i'll take it all right so if you won't
take it
alex you probably will have it so here
you go what do you think
here i need it hector delicious or what
are you getting cut off no we all do
i think so i think so you know what we
need whatever's in those coffee beans
every day that looks
really good hector we are so impressed a
plus today
this is headed your way yes can you
please bring those back to the station
we need that all right thanks hector you
have fun
drink some water you're welcome all
right